welcome to the big bang theory writer's
battle everyone i just got a couple of
businesses writers are in essence um
shy and retiring creatures uh
nerdy if you uh will forget the word and
writers on the big bang theory are the
most extreme example of that the world
has ever seen
these people are so uncomfortable right
now
i can't forget to tell you how much i'm
enjoying it
this is the only sitcom that i have ever
heard of that has a science consultant
and it's my belief that they only have a
science consultant because you people
are so nitpicky
um so uh without any we'll get to all
these questions in just a minute i have
a few questions of my own before we
begin uh really pretty much to anyone
who cares to answer probably uh you know
i'm looking for someone with a little
bit of seniority here but um
who was the genius that decided to kill
off uh professor proton
that was my fault
you bastard
the big bang theory at the time had been
nominated for three emmy awards and
hadn't won any
and bob newhart came on the show one
time and got one
and
i just thought to myself we have to kill
this guy
he's pretty good he wants me but he can
come back
well yeah that's the the good news about
it yeah he's uh there's really no death
in said class yeah
uh how did he how did he feel about him
i mean uh well chuck laurie and i called
him on the phone and i think it started
off with chuck saying hey bob so good
news bad news uh
we want you back on the show but we want
you to die and
i i asked him
are you familiar with star wars and he
said
no
no
so i gotta give him like a three-minute
crash course on star wars and luke and
obi-wan and then once he once he
understood what we were trying to do he
was actually very into it and very
excited
and uh star wars day is that an actual
day in the writers room do you guys do
anything for star wars day
um we actually everyone just looks at
them
i don't know star wars day in my house
this year on may 4th when we watch all
uh all six movies i say we i i was
sitting there alone by the end of it
other people
did come and i provided snacks and trees
uh unlike the show there was no cafe
onlia or uh attack of the scones
young people know that there are jobs in
the world uh just north of here where
you your job could be watching star wars
all day
it could be your job
i think maria got to come to the show
she has a young baby home and got to
come claiming it was a work event to
come watch it
i did
my husband is in the audience so now
that's blowing thank you
steve do you like star wars because uh
it was emotionally important to you as a
child
yes
so you but you acknowledge
right
like that it's great still i like you
i feel like star wars ideas you still
like star wars
well was it emotionally important to you
as a young man
i don't care for star wars
crazy you guys better settle down i will
put out my phantom menace right now
i've been watching all of it
steve taxation of trade routes were in
dispute that's why they blocked the
how did you planet to i get james l
jones uh who was in star wars after all
and is probably quite proud of it uh on
the show was he uh does he
get he when we approached him uh he was
very excited to do it and uh he was as
delightful to work with as he was on the
show and in that same episode we also
managed to get carrie fisher
and one really cool thing was uh james
earl jones are the voice of darth vader
but he was never on the set so on the
big bang theory stage was the first day
that james jones and carrie fisher ever
met in person
and when they approached each other
and when we approached each other the
first thing carrie said was dad
who over the years have you got the show
that you're particularly proud of
obviously the people we've just talked
about but i mean there's been such an
array of people who are you particularly
proud or happy to have someone well
steve stephen hart
yes
i don't know if i have david will
correct me on the science but we're
under the impression he invented the
universe
i may have oversimplified his work
because of the show it was the first
time i was ever in the room with stephen
hawking as well but we want but we wound
up kind of hanging with student hockey
for a while we we got invited to his
birthday party yeah yeah
um
and then and he also we we shot so drunk
i mean like if you're a science
consultant and stephen hawking's there
did you guys like throw down
we did a little bit
i i asked him about meeting the queen
and it takes
it takes professor a long time to answer
questions so it took him
and then you just the protocols you go
on with the rest of your conversation
and you wait for him to type in him
he uses a
uses his cheap muscle to move a mouse
the type so at the end of the meal it
came back with she's a right old bird or
something a very nice girl yeah
we've gotten to meet somebody through
the show that you're excited about i
think
well
how to train your dragon is like my
favorite movie
i'm totally freaking out craig i love
you
thanks very much
well are you
are you one of the more recent members
of the because you seem much younger and
more attractive than the other guys
uh yeah i've been on the show i think
we're kind of up here by how long we've
been on the show so
jeremy and i are our newer staff members
we've been on about two and a half now
is that an intimidating thing to walk
into a show like this where everything
is established and they have their way
with ideas about things
they're adorable oh yeah
there's a lot of uh it's intimidating
writing is hard and difficult but
you know you walk into a room where like
you said we get to talk about star wars
and we play d together
i think i think it's also important to
remember that when this show began it
it's easy to forget this but when the
show get began this kind of thing was
not as popular it wasn't like the
network was saying let's make a show
about geeks
i mean when it started there was a lot
of scoping within cbs because i was i
was in my 10th year or something at the
time but when you guys started the there
was a lot of you know yeah that will
work yeah you know trucks finally lost
his mind you know uh
and it was
you know we never set out to do
a show about geeks or nerds we you know
we
we were making a show about people we
knew right and you know the the basis
for the the original basis for the
characters was guys that i knew
when i had been a computer programmer
and i started talking to chuck about
those guys and then we we changed it we
didn't want to be programmers because
that had over the years become like the
microsoft money thing and we didn't want
it to be that
but um but it was still it was you know
it's just based on people we knew and
stuff we liked and then you know and
then you
you know bring these people aboard and
you know the the story
when maria
interviewed for the job
she was she was hired after she told the
story and i hope i get it right because
her husband is here but as best i
remember will you tell what had to do
with a present yeah
i i had asked for a phantom blade in
world of warcraft when i wrote from my
husband my birthday and he got me like
a tangible thing in the world instead
like i didn't remember what it was it
was like all i asked for
but and then you but you had also mined
for gold
for his birthday i had gotten him a
lunacy deck which is at the time this is
a long time ago guys it was a big deal
because i had to get all those cards and
it took forever and i was just
it took like a 10 hour time commitment i
felt like it wasn't too much and you can
make a phantom blade you know
or a weaponsmith so
so when you added these people with
problems like where my husband and i
fought because i bought him a virtual
present and he'd gotten some horrible
thing in the real world
and and then you know and steve holland
who loves star wars too much and eric
kaplan who doesn't appreciate a lot of
things like star wars or johnny carson
i i just feel that one of the good
things about science fiction is it helps
people think that the world is
comprehensible
and star wars appeals to this uh
mystical notion of the force
um
i don't know
eric
do you write a lot of
the point if you get to a situation now
where you have a cast which is very well
established then they know their
characters very well and and uh
hopefully everything is going to be fine
do they have
do you now consult at this point in the
life of a sitcom do you actually talk to
the actors about how things are going do
you take the rent with them
yeah we do talk to them yeah i get
excited about the stories we're doing
and i'll often tell them hey this is
coming up and uh you know johnny galecki
has told me that uh
that he actually enjoys that and finds
that helpful because he knows you know
sometimes it's just words on a page and
it's not readily apparent the tone of
the move we're going for so it's it's
very helpful for us to talk about it so
what if you join the show a few years in
or a little bit in the life of the show
and you've seen the actors do this work
uh and you have ideas for for how you
would like that character to go or a
story that would like to happen the
actor and the actor doesn't
feel that way about it does that cause
friction is there is there something
expression you definitely have never had
that experience
no i i think that i i it's just
something i remember the long life of
the when i was on the drew carey show
that after a long time
things get set and it's sometimes i
think more difficult for newer people in
the in the writers room to
find their own way within that you know
i mean are you very encouraging that are
you encouraging of young people well let
me ask that uh
i mean it is an easy place to work your
way into this it's not a huge writer's
room really i mean if this is all of you
guys it's not you uh i was a writer's
assistant for two years so i used my way
into it and uh just got some jokes on tv
and they promoted me and it uh
that's how i didn't do it so and i was a
fan of the show so i was familiar with
the characters and then i i worked on
the show like jeremy as an assistant for
uh a couple seasons before
and let's uh let's work our way up to
the more seasoned uh writers as we go
along
what was your experience like coming in
it was great i had worked with steve
milar and steve holland before at
nickelodeon so i had an easy transition
as far as that goes what did you do at
nickelodeon um it's called all that
drink
before you interviewed and got the job i
was on season three okay so that's quite
early there is a weirdness with the
actors though because you've been
watching the show and experiencing these
characters and then you spend all your
time imagining these characters and then
you meet them and they look like
something you think about all day long
but you don't know them it's weird it's
awkward yeah it is going to be like what
would you do in this situation because i
can't think of it tell me
that's kind of handy
uh same the three of us joined in season
three all
um so the show
hadn't quite taken off it sort of really
took i don't know i was saying there's a
correlation between when we joined
and you can probably
make your own call on what you think
about that
but
uh uh yes
oh no i mean
yeah it was just every show every
different show you go on has a different
language and it takes a little while to
kind of
learn the language of that show and the
dynamic
and find your place in it but i was very
fortunate to come on board when these
guys did so i didn't we could get
together at the end of the day
and um cry
we would rotate offices whose office we
were crying just like oh my god i feel
like i'm failing so wild oh good i'm not
alone
and then
um thank you all
and uh dave and eric you guys have been
on since the since the the beginning no
no i i dave has been on since the
beginning right i joined at the
beginning of season two season two eric
didn't you get your interview because
the they got the wrong eric kaplan yes
yes
there cannot
and somehow wires got crossed and miss
eric showed up
johnny wanted the air cap on the gaucho
from patagonia with one of those bowlers
that he would swing
and then i think jess amber said he was
like well he's the gaucho
this other capital of futurama so she
made the executive decision to send
my resume to
bill brady
we had met in new york a long time ago
when you were eric wrote for spy
magazine which was um i think sort of
the heir to in a way that was mad
magazine it was a mad magazine of the
golden ladies that's correct for
grown-ups right
but i i've known him in new york
and i i didn't know until afterwards
we'd had the wrong era tap with it
because when you came in i said oh my
god i know this guy he's right yeah eric
kaplan and this is not true of other
names are pretty fungible
from all eric happens we get together
there's a sort of a you know they don't
exceed a certain level of quality but we
also make sure we don't drop below a
certain level
now before we go to uh questions from
the floor uh dave you're the only person
that hasn't said a word so far
how's it going man
why do you think i've been here for
eight years
when we first started season one it was
incredible because we didn't know the
show but what we had was the bill's uh
experiences rooting in real life and
chuck's experiences of having created so
many shows and that was just an
incredible
positive force and i remember pitching
once before we even had the first table
read of the second episode and i pitched
an idea and chuck looked at me and he
said if we do that you will ruin the
show
and i said well let's not do that
and since you guys seem to be into
nickelodeon i just need to point out
that steve holland and i also did the
first season of icarly
not quite the cheer i thought you
prepared for it come on
who are you all right uh we're not going
to go from uh
from the floor i believe do we have that
set up yes we do
uh uh one moment while we arrange the
microphone because uh apparently i'm
throwing this at you as a
great you're surprise questions from the
floor cover card yeah it's never been
done
uh so uh when you uh
when you're ready you're come on up
she's speaking the young lady and i was
about to step forward 10 to 15.
we're not judging you we just can't hear
you
all right
thank you for your hard work we all
appreciate you very much we like your
shirt thank you thank you i thought you
would appreciate that
um i would like to know are you ever
going to fix the elevator
i think those stairs are the only
exercise those guys get
the thing about the elevator on the
stairs
so there's a there are a couple of
problems in shooting a sitcom and one is
where do you shoot a scene where people
walk and talk
so you can shoot it in a car where they
sort of drive and talk
um or you can kind of do
you know a little outside set or
something like that but what this
stairwell gave us
was a place to have walk and talk
conversations that was that was organic
so to make that stairwell
the we they dug a hole in the floor of
stage 25 at warner brothers when we did
the pilot and stage 25 was the best
stage to shoot in and when we got picked
up to series they said well we're going
to move you to another stage which was
the worst stage and chuck laurie said
great just dig a hole in that stage and
they said oh okay you can stay where you
are so
yeah
um i was just thinking that you could
have the characters fix it
just saying okay
these people are professionals you could
actually have it
yeah i think a fan might know that this
shaft was damaged beyond repair by the
rocket fuel that blew up in it
which we saw on the show so
oh
i feel such a fool
yes okay hello okay
question is how hard is it to add new
characters because when you start with
the original characters then you added
bernadette and amy like how do you
decide to add those characters
there was no uh
grand plan at the time
for bernadette and amy to go on and
become the major staples in the show
that they are
they they did one appearance and we love
them in their auditions and it just
worked out and we thought they're great
let's put more of them in the show and
that and that's how that happened and uh
it's kind of how we we go at all these
things if we get somebody and we add
them and it seems to be going well uh
we'll do more
yeah
thanks very much
i feel bad i don't know
what was it
hello um i just wanted to say um that i
really i was really happy with the
progress that sheldon and amy made in
the last season
um
you know both individually and as uh two
parts of a relationship um despite the
fact i know amy says that sheldon's
unknown flight risks
despite that i think we were all a
little surprised at the end of season
seven with uh his exit so i was just
wondering if
sheldon's walkabout is gonna be
something positive for his relationship
with amy um and if they're going to find
happiness with each other
she's asking for spoilers
well he didn't leave because of amy and
i i i would argue that they do have
their own weird brand of happiness right
now
um i i
that kiss moment
uh on the train i think is pretty good
and and one other just while we're
talking about the kiss uh that was such
a stressful time in the writer's room
like we were sweating and pacing and
trying to get that moment right to the
point that there is a version of the
kiss scene that we wrote a completely
different version of it that we wrote
that no one has ever seen because we
were so panicked that we needed to get
it right
what happened to the different versions
of the kissing he was uh in the other
version
in the version that's on tv he kind of
went at her and he was mad because he
felt that he was tricked to go on a
train right there's a kinder gentler
version where he kisses her just because
he's having such a lovely experience on
the train but i'm really happy with the
way we did it so
yes i like that book too uh yes
who else am i asking you're standing
there
what a surprise come on
thank you for a great show i've been a
fan since day one uh my questions are
just a follow-up to the previous one and
it's on everyone's mind will um
amy and sheldon ever get down to
business beyond a kiss
easy easy this is a pg battle come on
what spirit are you asking that in
i mean
if you're relating to the show almost as
if it's it's real
and you're enjoying it as something that
you have an emotional connection with
that you would feel bad to hear that the
you know molly collection of people on
this panel have figured it out and are
planning it right
eric catholic dreams
direct questions from eric are a big
part of the writer's room
you're now having that we that we all
have from time to time
i'm actually trying to be supportive i
feel like
you have a certain enjoyment that you're
going to get from watching the show and
i'm wondering if you thought through
that if you asked us supposing we said
your question was or is amy ever going
to be happy and we said
no
you're going to be happy
it might it might make your relationship
to the character of amy kind of been
kind of different i think
does that answer your question
or or does it just scare you
i mean i think for for me um and i'm i'm
in a great position because uh
because my my relationship with the show
these days is part time so i get to come
in and see what steve and the guys have
done
and the amazing thing about these two
characters is that they
sheldon will not move at all
and amy will not let him not move
and it's this
just watching
amy move sheldon
is incredible because i will say i would
say there's absolutely no way sheldon
would ever do such and such and then
steve will get angry and then
and then show how show how that would
happen and you look at it and say yeah
that would move him that that would you
know and a lot of it has to do with
sheldon doesn't want to lose anything he
doesn't want to be with amy on her terms
but he doesn't want to lose her and so
that lets him move forward also
everything eric said
i think that was a very thoughtful
question thank you very much i'm sorry
you've had such a hard time
thanks for all the laughs and also from
two and a half men
laughs there
which is none of us on this panel but we
will pass that along yeah
i thought i saw phil braddy's sorry
anyways it seems like it could be a
blast to be cracking jokes for a few
hours a day writing jokes is there a
certain point where it becomes like a
roller coaster where it's just too much
of a good thing and it's like a real job
yes
as delightful as we seem right now we
can get old after a while trust me
i calculated i think we spent 1500 hours
a season together
i think the the the myth is that you
know for for actors um working on a
sitcom is actually a dream job it's
quite easy and you don't really have to
work that hard but for writers it's an
extremely difficult job these guys work
very late at night and really it's not a
fun business being funny look look at
them
this is as good as we work out here
any of these people are in sunlight for
the first time this year
uh let's take another question thanks
madam
all right my name is marshall force so
eric you've been calling me out this
whole time
and
have i well let's talk about this don't
come back
don't get eric made
uh anyways why did you have them
clicking refresh because that's the one
thing
our experiences of buying tickets at
comic con many many years comic-con did
change the system this year a little bit
where they also don't tell you what
number you are online i'm not saying
they do that to screw us but we're on
you comic-con
we wanted to see if there would be
someone who would spot it
into the
secret uh order of big bang gas squad
and believe it or not the real thing of
buying tickets when you just stare at
the screen and don't say anything not as
interesting on tv as you might imagine
they're earning some money they should
say words
uh may i interrupt just for a second i
have a question of my own uh this season
uh penny was crashed with will wheaton
in the low budget movie cereal april yes
yeah is there a is there any chance to
ever get to see the whole movie is that
something today
i mean we're kind of busy writing the tv
show so probably not
but we might have a trailer that we can
show you right now
who are you under there
well welcome uh will be of course the uh
the man behind syria well if there's any
chance if there was a serious movie
would you do it i think it would work
yes
yes i've actually pitched a lot of story
ideas to steve
how
close are you to actually making that
happen because i'm in i want to be part
of this you know
we're not but every time we talk about
it we get really excited the idea that
this is
kind of
it we got more and more excited about
how we wanted it to be real moving i
think it should be a kickstarter
campaign
and kaylee loved having that hair glued
to herself
that's not the way i remember it
the word wasn't love no it was um i
think if you were to take the concept of
love and then fill up all the space in
the known melting you would get kaylie's
emotion at the other end
well uh you play yourself of course
how close is that to who you are are you
really um because
you know
i uh i i am not as evil
as far as anyone knows
as as evil
started out um when the relationship
between will wheaton and sheldon sort of
changed and um and he became more of an
ally and a friend to him
that character started to shift a lot
closer to who i am uh in in my life and
so what i'm hearing is a big denial of
evil
very strong
that's well i mean i think that's the
most appropriate way to do that
but we did accurately build your house
on the stage you did this is really
funny so phil had come to my house for a
housewarming party and and uh when
when sheldon came over to my house for
for the for the party uh i walked onto
the set and everything in that set
looked like my house
there's even a couch there that i wanted
to buy from my house but my wife talked
me out of uh and then we hung a lot of
my art on the walls in there that that
ridiculous velvet was the crusher
painting
is actually i own that
hey the guy that asked about refresh
he's the real deal too
uh looking for the questions back to the
floor uh will has now joined the panel
of course i don't know if that affects
your question choice you know maybe in
blue does it no okay
in season two episode two sheldon says
that he was diagnosed with
pernicious anemia now is that in the mix
diagnosis
or does he actually have to get shots
every week
because i do
we guessed that
sheldon is sheldon is a hypochondriac
and i think that a lot of the things
that he claimed when it gets to medical
stuff and we saw
when uh when leonard was dating a doctor
he does a lot of when if he says
diagnosed with that may have been by
himself
so
there's a lot of um there's a lot of
munch housing with with sheldon and uh
you can't take him at his word when he
has a medical condition
but he is not crazy according to whoever
his mother didn't do
there you are and the next person please
hi uh huge fan um i'm also a teacher and
i have a lot of young adults who are
also really huge fans um and so they
kind of look up to these characters who
are nerds and different geeky which is
great
um but i was wondering if kind of for
that younger audience
there was going to be any more
flashbacks we'd see any more childhood
idols or maybe a high school reunion
no immediate plans but
that sounds great do you do you have a
script because
quite a bunch more and we're tired
uh and i'm trying to decode your shirt
i've
which is work
i work out
they're very clever
yes lydia
hi i am miriam norris and i wanted to
know why you hate aquaman so much
you uh there's a lot because of who we
are there's a lot of i mean you've heard
about eric's diatribe against star wars
and why it's responsible for the olds of
men but
they're steve hates them if it makes you
feel better i also don't like it
i'm not a writer on the show but i
actually really like aquaman oh
see eric that's how you play crap
i i get to play i do the voice of
aqualab on teen titans and teen
i think it makes sense that for a planet
that is primarily covered with water you
would have superheroes that exist in
that environment and i've heard what you
said but i don't think anybody on this
stage heard what you said say it again
with the last part of your of your
comment my grandfather is paul l norris
and he is the creator
failure to say on a personal load of
aquaman has always been my favorite
and the scripted material that they have
me say when i'm up here
defeats me
yes hi my name is ken i was wondering
why did you guys burn down the comic
book store are we getting it back
there
uh there will be a comic book store in
the future uh we're figuring out exactly
how that's gonna work out but
the show will not go on without a comic
book store i promise
yeah
big bang theory two and a half man
crossover when
how many guy and simpsons are doing it
so so season 22 then
yeah
hi
i just want to say first thanks for
making the physics understandable to
people my dad finally understands what i
studied in school
is it physics yeah
and then moving on we saw the characters
really mature in their relationships and
as adults do we see them maybe moving on
forward and hearing the pitter patter of
their little feet to move to pass the
nerd kingdom on to in the future
some of our cast is already very little
there's no plans for babies at any point
i don't know big bang baby is
yeah
hi um
as
uh watching the show i'm a big fan where
my whole family watches it together
these characters are probably the most
real i've ever seen
we talk about them all the time
and what as star wars fans i wanted to
ask do you think star star wars is more
of science fiction or science fantasy
i'm going off of what eric thinks
eric has strong feelings about this
it's it's sort of eternal there's fish
fulfillment isn't it yeah it's like
replace
science with magic and get the same
thing exactly
everybody listen to her don't pick on me
sometimes eric i feel you leave the rest
of us behind
yes sir
hi i think it's been really interesting
how the female characters have changed
over the course of the show i'm trying
to provide us good comment about that
we agree
from the beginning the show is written
has been written without a plan
so in when you sit down to write an
episode you say
presented with what happens in this
episode what would the characters do
and that begins to define them and
there's you know it's not that you know
there's no road map set out it's the
circumstance
you find out more about the characters
and when you look at the growth of the
guys on the show i think you can point
to the ladies for a big reason behind it
but i think
but also i think characters in order to
care about them and you know will was
talking about how his character at first
was kind of broad and then
that doesn't sustain after a while you
have to find out who the character is
otherwise it's uncomfortable to watch
and so i think that's the natural
evolution of all characters hopefully
things are working well is they become
realer and you know more about them and
i have no end to that sentence
yes
when will
leonard and penny get married and what
crazy events will happen at their
wedding
i don't
they are engaged but the wedding is
sometime off in the future and they're
not they're not in a rush penny
penny's first goal is to put the date
far enough in the future so everyone
knows for a fact that she's not pregnant
and then
we'll go from there
i think it's season 22 crossover
will be a while thank you yes and the
next question from the lady of the green
card
um
even if it's like 20 seasons from now
have you guys thought about how you
might end the show
i have thoughts but i i'm not going to
see them right now
yeah that's about the time but you know
in my head the big bang theory universe
exists in the same snow globe as saying
elsewhere
you're welcome it was good these are
nice yeah
yes sir and the attractive shirt
thank you very much
a couple seasons ago there was an
episode in which we see glimpses of mrs
wallowitz which is contrary to the joke
in which she's always seen but never
heard i'm sorry i've always heard it but
never seen
what was the reaction of viewers to that
you were a viewer
it really seems more in your bailiwick
but
i think it was not so easy when you're
asking the question is it hey
a large scale golf into the darkness
with your bright shirt
you can also see her in the wedding on
the roof yeah so as the camera as the
google satellite camera pulls back
really fast and at the end of season
five in the ring you can see a big pink
blob
it's like a big front sight here
yes
i've been a big fan of big bang theory
from since it started and my
favorite character is penny and will you
ever reveal her last name
at this point we've come so far it's a
bit of a superstition for us so
it's
wait till we have to wrestle if and when
they do get married and how we get
around that part so
would it be satisfying if we promised
that at some point we'll reveal if we'll
reveal her last name
and i think i think this is probably our
last question so
make it
uh hey
my name is jack buckley from san diego
hey jack
looking good what does that jackman ask
what you're what are you wearing uh it's
a costume based off a character i made
uh my question is now that you've burned
down the stores stewart doesn't have a
place to go and you kind of just threw
that under the rug to deal with sheldon
i want to know uh what what kind of
story progression will happen with him
will he run the new store that you were
talking about or will he move in with
one of the guys
what are you going to do with them
stuart does make a move which started at
the end of the season uh living with mrs
wallace
and when we come back he's still there
and as far as the future of the store he
uh you know we're working on that but
there will be a store in the future
all right let's squeeze in one more and
uh yeah also have another question all
right yes
hi my name is ashley and i was just
wondering who's in charge of picking the
t-shirts the guys wear on the
show married quickly
uh our costume our costume designer very
quickly
are you a merry quickly fan is that
i'd like to thank the writers and
science consultant of course will we
thank you very much everybody
you